o meu nome então garcía sayán primeiro
de agradecer a oportunidade está aqui de
ter liberdade para falar e expressar
poder contar um pouco da minha história
minha trajetória o que me fez e de
encontro com a alteração no projeto
collor city é falar sobre liberdade pra
mim é sinônimo de arte de criação e de
sonho há como se estivesse falando tudo
a mesma coisa assim
então quando eu penso em liberdade
eu penso que é meio que o poder de
criação assim o poder de você poder
criar de poder pensar e sonhar coisas e
correr atrás disso assim e fazer com que
aquele sonho torne uma coisa material
real assim que aqui você já é uma
realidade e parte de ser livre também
acho que é uma responsabilidade sem
garantias assim é um momento em que você
se dispõe a fazer alguma coisa sem ter a
garantia de que aquilo vai dar certo de
que aquilo do que aquilo no que aquilo
vai dar sim então acho que as pessoas
estão muito acomodadas assim assim
é muito mais fácil você vender sua
liberdade em troca de conforto do que
você correr atrás do seu conforto
em troca da sua própria liberdade assim
então acho que é uma coisa que fica
muito mais como dá sim para as pessoas
hoje em dia ela teve o seu ganha pão e
saber exatamente o que vai acontecer no
dia seguinte do que ela não sabe o que
vai acontecer daqui a dez minutos na
vida dela e como ela vai plantar e
correr fazer para que aquilo continue se
desenvolvendo e seja de bosque que
sustente a sua realidade que aquilo seja
realmente real assim então acho que isso
essas experiências a esse tipo de visão
acabou me dando um conceito de que você
trabalha para o seu sonho você ou você
sonha o trabalho de seu sonho você
trabalha pessoa de alguém então acho que
é meio que isso que vai acabar
acontecendo assim se você não tiver uma
opinião própria assim é então acho que
nesse meio tempo eu fui o nesse meio
tempo de concepção assim que começar a
enxergar a vida
eu resolvi que ia ser grafiteiro era
moleque eu tinha 10 anos de idade e até
então eu queria ser jogador de futebol o
skate sair mas não sabia que eu queria
fazer eu comecei então a ter mais
contato com a rua através de skate e
comecei a observar a rua de uma outra
forma assim comecei a ver que que os que
as paredes o que tinha no meu caminho
não é simplesmente um lugar ali uma
coisa que eu passo que não me
representar nada assim aquele corrimão
tinha virado um obstáculo à rampa tinha
virado 11 outro obstáculo um saco de
lixo um outro obstáculo tudo era uma
possibilidade de criar alguma coisa nova
e me superar e fazer aquilo aquilo
continua caminhando a acontecer coisas
novas eu ver a parada de outra maneira
assim houve comecei a ver a cidade e as
ruas e amizade tudo que aconteceu de
outra forma a partir dessa constatação
assim dessas mudanças na realidade eu
comecei a observar o grafite e comecei a
ver as paredes e as paredes começaram a
falar comigo eu vi que os muros estavam
falando que é porque a cidade não estava
quieto que tinha muita coisa acontecendo
que só que só não viu quem não queria
sim e eu por sendo criança com 10 anos
de idade a única coisa que conversava
comigo na rua eram os desenhos eram que
tinha na parede não era uma placa de
aluga-se uma placa de vende se ou alguém
fazendo algum outro tipo de coisa era
simplesmente uma uma relação que eu
tenho com a cidade infantil assim como
acho que qualquer outra qualquer um ser
humano que esteja livre a receber coisas
novas e ele está predisposto a enxergar
essa realidade é essa conversa estava
acontecendo
eu vi então que tinha uma comunicação
gigante acontecer nem da cidade e que
naquela época com dez anos o facebook
não existia mas existe um facebook
analógico as pessoas estavam conversando
através dos muros ela se inscreveu nos
seus muros
ela se comunicavam elas mostravam de
onde elas vinham para onde ela sozinho
qual eram os seus interesses o que ela
escrevia então isso começou a mudar um
pouco a minha visão eu comecei a ver que
isso era um movimento feito por crianças
não comecei a descobrir que o grafite
ele é um movimento feito por crianças é
um movimento onde eu fui acaba
nesses 18
anos de trajetória de grafite eu fui ver
q
a maioria dos dos principais grafiteiros
começaram com mais de 15 anos começaram
eu comecei com 10 o outro começou com 12
conversando com com grandes artistas aí
eu vi que eles também começaram com o
máximo no máximo 15 anos então é um
movimento construído por crianças
sustenta nos sonhos de criança assim com
uma conversa que aparentemente é
infantil em que a sociedade num num
absorvem não consegue entender acha que
aquilo é tipo uma uma coisa que tá aí
pra denegrir e não o que é uma coisa
natural assim da cidade
então é isso eu comecei a perceber que a
gente está todo dentro de um mesmo
cenário e que hoje a gente respeita a
gente não respeita eu acho que essa e se
esse lado de não respeitar a parte
negativa da coisa eu posso não concordar
mas eu não respeitar é onde entra a
parte vivem em comunidade que eu acho
que a gente está meio que levando de uma
maneira não muito cuidadosa assim acho
que a gente deveria observar mais a
natureza das coisas em vez de ficar
batendo de frente com elas e ver que as
pessoas naturais existentes
então eu comecei a observar um pouco
disso nesse meio desse tempo passei por
diversas experiências da minha vida e
uma delas foi aparentemente negativo foi
quando eu estava fazendo grafite
eu tinha uma autorização verbal do
proprietário e isso perante a lei alguma
coisa legal porém na realidade não
funciona muito bem na prática assim né
eu comecei a ver que a opinião pública
vem antes da opinião pessoal por exemplo
estava fazendo um fui pedir uma
autorização para fazer um grafite tal
bate na porta e pedir estava pintando do
outro lado da rua um cara pintada na
parede branco normal o pintando a parede
colorida aqui pintando a parede branco
lá até normal até a polícia passar sem
que a polícia passou a primeira coisa
que fez foi parar e perguntar se eu
tinha autorização autorização pra que né
porque não parou para perguntar se
aquele cara tem autorização da pinta a
parede branca pintada de azul amarelo e
verde com a diferença tipo assim não
consigo ver nenhuma nenhuma diferença é
a única diferença é o que está na cabeça
das pessoas como a pessoa visualiza
aquela situação então
aquilo já tem um preconceito da
sociedade que aquilo é negativo e depois
eu como agente transformador o agente
mudança é uma pessoa que está preocupada
com o meio ambiente que estou batendo à
porta e me pré respondeu a pintar de
graça ou não de qualquer forma mudar o
ambiente pra mim aquilo era uma coisa
completamente negativa como se fosse uma
pegadinha do estado assim o cara botar a
bola no meio da rua e ficou esperando
batendo um papo vai papo vem vai estar
bola alguém bastasse a bola uma hora ou
outra é um spray que sobrou no fundo da
sua casa risca aparelho é natural a
gente boa não tem por que ser punido por
isso assim então acho que a partir daí
eu comecei a visualizar passei por uma
situação e nessa situação fica a minha
palavra contra o policial por você tem
autorização não tem autorização
e aí o dono da casa não quis sair de
casa porque não sabia se aquilo é legal
se não era assim que ele tinha
autorizado era tipo legítimo no ar ele
fingiu que não estava com minha palavra
contra o policial
eu não tive muito o que fazer eu falei
pô você só poderia me liberar porque não
tenho que fazer o cara me deixou pintar
e aí fica aquela palavra final fui
liberado mas eu voltei com isso na minha
cabeça como resolver aquela situação
porque eu estava legalmente e não fiz
nada ilegal não comprei nada ilícito
comprei um material em uma loja de
construção que estava escrito lá que é
proteger parede na hora de prender à
parede
eu estava fazendo uma coisa
completamente ilegal e aquilo estava eu
estava sendo proibido de fazer aquilo
voltei para casa com esse pensamento e
aí eu comecei a pensar numa proposta foi
aí que surgiu a idéia de comer city né
aquela idéia de de conscientização assim
uma idéia de descriminalização do
artista e da pessoa que tipo utilizado o
espaço urbano para se expressar tanto
como esteticista que também tinha uma
visão marginalizado o parco hoje em dia
ou o artista circense a pessoa que se
expressa na rua que toca a seu sua
música
eu comecei a pensar por aí e como ea
partir daí o povo à parte o mais óbvio
hoje em dia há dez anos atrás não era
isso mas hoje a internet conectar as
pessoas de um lado
para o outro e no meio disso dá uma
garantia dada uma autorização por
escrito real de que aquela conversa
existiu
então a partir disso eu criei essa essa
idéia a partir das 10h a necessidade que
elas que a cidade apresentou pra mim é a
minha realidade e tentando solucionar
esse problema eu tenho que solucionar o
problema de milhares de grafiteiros que
precisam todo dia passa por esse tipo de
situação e sendo que a intenção dele é
completamente o oposto mas a sociedade a
mídia acaba forçando ensinando as
pessoas a pensarem dessa forma assim tão
opinião pública acaba vindo antes da
opinião pessoal pessoal não pára pra
avaliar o que está fazendo e
simplesmente ela já julga que aquilo é
ilegal e ela a barra aquela situação e
da revolução da nossa conversa barro o
cotidiano barra com que o aaa a cidade
seja mais colorida mais harmoniosa
então eu partir disso eu criei essa
plataforma plataforma ela se desenvolve
com o google maps lá dentro você entra
dentro do site você tem lamúrias
disponíveis ipi une a fome com a vontade
de comer eu diria assim é que tem o
grafiteiro de um lado e o dono de muro
que não conhece o grafiteiro do outro
então as pessoas se conectam a gente
simplesmente faz uma ponte não cobra
nada não têm pedágio não tenho nada
nesse sentido e as pessoas se conectam a
partir daí a coisa começa a funcionar
entre elas são de pessoa para pessoa e
há quem ganha é a população a cidade
ficou pintada isso um resultado que eu
acho interessante pra caramba é o que eu
tenho buscado assim com o calor city
hoje a gente tem como resultado é esse é
o site é como ele funciona e tem um
sistema de mapas como falei pra vocês a
ele tem um ouro verde que ele está
disponível amarelo que já foi reservado
e o colorido é que ele já foi pintada
aí hoje em dia a gente já tem mais de 5
mil mudas disponíveis no mundo inteiro
tem o site tem três línguas inglês
português e espanhol
a gente tem mais
os muros que já foram pintados tem por
bastante interesse eu vejo muita
motivação e da população em si assim
tanto do lado do dono da casa do
proprietário quanto do grafiteiro vez
tem um retorno positivo pra caramba em
foi já faz três anos e meio quatro anos
que só está no ar
já faz um tempo que eu venho buscando
isso essa relação é sem ter relação com
os grafiteiros e estudando isso eu tive
um grande apoio dos meus apoiadores e da
dos desenvolvedores da ideia hoje em dia
ela não está tão mais incentivada já
ganhamos bilhões de prêmios aí que
talvez tenha sido o interesse de quem
estava envolvido até então hoje em dia o
site tá aí autonomamente funcionando
continuando com pessoas utilizando muros
sendo pintados com o mínimo de recursos
possível a minha idéia eu continuo
incentivando que que exista mais corpo
que as aparentes e já pintaram que a
sociedade consiga visualizar o grafite o
grafiteiro de uma outra forma
esses são alguns resultados do site
são muros que já foram pintadas são
plataformas que estão aí sendo
desenvolvidas pessoas que estão se
conhecendo
existem histórias muito interessantes
que ver que vão vir a não acontecer
nicos diversas essa lateral do prédio
foi pintada na uma das grandes
principais avenidas de são paulo por um
grafiteiro do interior que teve essa
chance de pintar também com um grande
artista renomado de são paulo que pintou
outro lado do prédio então acho que isso
é uma coisa que está abrindo portas para
as pessoas conhecerem temos outras
histórias muito interessantes de gringo
que veio para o brasil e ficou na casa
de uma pessoa há um ano atrás pintou
essa casa eles ficaram super amigos essa
pessoa já mudou de casa e hoje ele volta
para o brasil ainda encontra essas
pessoas e manda um email pra gente
agradecendo que por causa dessa
possibilidade e teve um reencontro as
pessoas se conheceram ele foi criado uma
família um muro nem existe mais mas esse
gringo e essa pessoa brasileiras estão
conectadas e suplantou
gerou alguma coisa positiva então acho
que o principal o principal idéia do
site e do do grafiteiro dessa história
toda em si é isso é mostrar que o
grafite é um ele veio pra unir o site
agora está aí nessa intenção de deo new
ela tem mais umas fotos da sessão fotos
de locais que têm que tem dentro da
plataforma tão tanto como locais de mais
ou menos estruturas e ver que o
interesse da população é desde a classe
alta até a as pessoas de menos condição
o que isso não interfere porque a arte é
uma coisa aberta que que liberta que
está aí pra juntar tudo mesmo com arte
eu brinco que é o bobo da corte ele está
entre um lado e outro é o que conecta
assim como se fosse o futebol é assim é
um gosto em comum então acho que acho
que é por aí assim que o que eu venho
lidando com a minha vida criando esse
tipo de projeto brincando um pouco a
liberdade com o presente que eu tenho na
minha mão e eu acho que é um pouco disse
assim eu venho falando um pouco disso
criei essa plataforma
sigo defendendo o grafite como uma
natureza da cidade e como sendo um
elemento nativa assim como sendo um
bicho nativo da cidade como sendo um
animal uma planta nativa daqui então de
das grandes cidades grandes megalópoles
assim não local pra você um animal uma
espécie pra você querer terminar é um
bicho nativo que tem sua beleza e que
merece o respeito e tem a sua função
assim dentro da natureza então acho que
essa é a grande importância porque eu
estou aqui porque eu acho que a maneira
de me expressar e o que ao lado da minha
vida assim como a liberdade como exerço
a minha liberdade ea responsabilidade
que eu tenho com isso acho que é meio
que essa sim eu gostaria de falar pra
galera que eu gostaria de de mensagem
que gostaria de deixar meio que é essa
liberdade existe essa liberdade o
trabalho do seu sonho por sonho de
alguém e é que isso tem um videozinho eu
vou passar que falam
também um vídeo sobre o projeto
um exemplo só acontece quando conectamos
pessoas com idéias poderosos e esses
caras têm um
eles querem fazer do mundo um lugar mais
colorido porque as coisas deixam as
pessoas mais felizes mais criativas e
criam um lugar melhor para se viver
nos conectamos esses caras eles
conectaram todo mundo
um lado está atuando muros o outro lado
está pintando eles
a evolução está apenas começando junte
se a ela e faça da sua cidade
a color siri bom aí acho que é isso o
vídeo mostra um pouquinho sobre essa o
funcionamento essa brincadeira toda o
que o a emoção está envolvido toda essa
história eu acho que a intenção total
essa mil nós precisamos de nós mesmos
essa questão é só uma frase da música
voz ativa dos racionais eu acho que isso
daí resume muito assim a gente precisa
de nós mesmos os humanos precisam ser
mais humanas e se tomar tomar a frente
da situação e fazer as coisas
acontecerem não ficar muito pedindo
buscando imploram e sim por brincar com
o seu presente em uma conta do seu
cenário das pessoas que estão em volta
acho que isso daí é o principal um
sentido de unidade equilíbrio fluidez é
isso